how to build a team when you don't have
money
i got a great question from our youtube
viewers jacqueline who wrote in that
shot colleen is a special person she's a
subscriber on the channel comments on a
lot of my videos always leaves
awesome comments always i always feel
great after getting a comment from
jacqueline so jacqueline thank you
and this video is just for you she wrote
in the same evan i have a question
what would be your suggestion for
someone who's trying to build a team
with low funds
but an abundance of ideas this is a
super common challenge for entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs have e-d-d
e-a-d-d entrepreneur whatever add for
entrepreneurs we have ideas
all the time nina's laughing at me as
i'm making this video
we have tons of ideas okay entrepreneurs
have ideas we're ideas
we're like little arsonists we light all
these little fires we don't actually
execute and do anything with them
and that's the problem that's your first
problem you have to find
one idea that you love and you need to
focus like you gotta focus your time
your energy
on making this one thing happen so pick
your best idea your favorite idea and
just focus on that instead of spending
ten percent of your time and five
percent of your time right divide it up
you're too scattered but this is common
everybody is a lot of entrepreneurs are
we we have a hard time we like the
visionary big picture stuff
you have a hard time staying focused but
you gotta focus you need to have focus
when you bring in a team remember it
doesn't have to be full time okay does
not have to be a full-time worker the
first guy i hired for my business
was for one hour a day one hour a day
that freed up an hour of my time to go
do other stuff
and he did a better job and stuff i
didn't like doing so you want to make
sure as much as possible in your
business that you're
doing the higher level big picture ceo
stuff
you can't always do it especially when
you're just starting up and you're a
one-person show
but you know your highest value is going
to come from doing the things that
you're really good at and you love
and you want to start delegating off the
low value stuff
that still needs to get done in your
business but it shouldn't be you doing
it
so part-time workers interns
i brought on you know high school and
college interns and foreign language
interns
i've brought on again part-time workers
i've used
websites like odesk and elance odessa is
my favorite now though they've merged so
i don't know what that relationship
looks like but
i still have a team on odesk that i love
and do great work including christina
who does all these videos thank you
christine i love you
i've even had people who are who are
fans so
i've done uh you know people who are who
are active in my community and who like
what i stand for they want to find ways
to help
just to volunteer there's this arturo
who takes some of these videos and
translates them into spanish
just because he feels like spanish
entrepreneurs need to
get this entrepreneurial education and
there's kevin
uh who you know wants to learn how to be
an entrepreneur wants to help out on
some of the projects i'm working on so
he's he's hopping on some stuff
so when you stand for something
important when people believe in what
you're doing
when something powerful something that
means something to them don't want to
get involved and help out
and the last thought that i have for you
is
look at creating joint ventures and so
you know you're bringing somebody on to
your team
you have to decide is somebody who's
going to be just an employee or somebody
who i'm comfortable doing a partnership
with
and a lot of the stuff i've done in my
business is i've partnered with people
on specific projects so i own my
business hundred percent i don't have
investors i don't have partners it's
just me
but i have jv's joined venture ships
with
a number of people on specific projects
and so
that all works differently could be 50
50 70 30. whatever
you know ratio you think makes the most
sense is simply going to be based on how
much
each person brings to the table but
you're not spending a lot of money
to do this or any money to do this
they're investing their time but you
have to make sure people get paid
for what they're doing right so if
they're going to invest a lot of their
time up front
and not get any payment they got to get
something to return on the end which is
some kind of joint ventureship in the
project i'd be hesitant to give up
a percentage of your business unless you
feel the person is really really really
really really the right fit for your
company
that's my advice thanks for all the
comments believe because you're watching
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below
let me know what you think ask a
question
tell me how to feel better leave in the
comments below and you can click on my
face to subscribe to the channel
thank you so much i'll see you soon